[Music]
n
this program is for educational purposes
only the content is not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
diseases nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician the
statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA testimonials are
shared as individual experiences of the
individual results VAR and may not be
typical we do not make any claims
regarding health or income as an
empowered individual you have options
available
we all right let's go ahead and open up
the doors to the zoom room yes this is
Becca Dukes here on daily with Doc and
it is Monday we are going to be starting
up our Monday show again and I am so
excited to be able to uh bring to you
some fresh information coming from one
of our naturopathic Physicians here
within our team and I'm
um I'm just you know
folks when you're looking for answers
and you put it out there you find them
so if you have been trying to figure out
something that might be missing this
might just be the show for you as we're
going to be taking another look at a
different angle when it comes to
identifying things that are going on in
the body so this program is being
sponsored by daily with Doc and if you
were referred to by or referred to this
program by somebody specific make sure
that you get back with them as they
cared enough and took the time to share
this program with you care enough about
them and thank them for taking the time
so if you have any questions in regards
to what you hear today they're going to
be your point of contact in getting the
information that you need at uh
achieving and and bringing in the
products that are recommended if you
hear something that is of interest to
you now if there's nobody to than nobody
referred you to this program you found
us on your own or are part of the
critical Health news or daily with Doc
newsletters teams or subscrib ERS and
you would like more information just
simply do a reply to that email that you
received or go to daily withth do.com
use that contact us or if you have
questions questions at Daily
with.com again my name is Becca Dukes as
the hostess of this program and also the
director of student services it is with
great honor and privilege to introduce
to you um our special guest
and it's kind it's her debut and I'm so
excited to be able to bring her on this
is Dr Cara ringland now Dr ringland she
specializes in idology she is a
naturopathic medicine doctor traditional
naturopathic medicine doctor and she is
just super excited to be able to add a
nutritional aspect to her process
her practice it's a whole it's a process
right it's a whole process when we're
trying to figure out what's going on in
our bodies and then
also
obtain what we need in order to service
our bodies in the way that they need to
to obtain Optimal Health right Dr K yes
well I am eager to be here thank you so
much for inviting me to this show and it
is a delight to bring Wellness to the
field and to the Forefront as we of
course know we're postco there's a lot
of healing that we're all seeking and I
feel like the the world is ready for
taking action and being responsible for
our wellness and uh for those of you who
may not be familiar with
iridology it's the study of the iris of
the eye so we look at the fabric of the
iris the patterns the textures the
colors
that are all shaped within the womb so
it's all of our genetic information
essentially that is pro presented in our
Iris and as we know the windows or the
eyes of the windows to the soul and what
we have discovered uh in Matthew 6:24 I
believe it is it's that let thine eye be
single let thine eye be pure of light
and so what we have discovered is that
when our Wellness when we're in a
holistic Wellness our eyes reflect our
Wellness so if you've ever had small
children you might have noticed when
they get the glassy eye the weepy eye
they're sick you can sense it and they
don't even have to speak because it's
usually uh when they're little right so
in this regard we can use the eyes as a
detector system that's a non-invasive
way to be able to look at things so now
to give you a little bit of my
background I started studying Natural
Health in the year
2000 um I had a unique background I was
raised as uh I was homeschooled actually
uh in northern Idaho um by my mother who
was a master herbalist and so my
education in Natural Health began before
I could speak by learning about the
herbs we made all the teas tines
medicines for our congregation at our
church and I learned a lot about Animal
Care and small children in particular
and uh applied that throughout my life
because at 12 years old I had um
developed chronic hives and uticaria so
my whole body was covered in welts um
and I tried everything and that was the
first time I got taken to a naturopathic
physician in northern Idaho Dr birsa and
he was the first person who told me
about um uh Candida and so learning
about candida at 12 years old showed me
a lot about how to uh read labels and
start to become responsible for
everything that I put in my mouth now
through this process and and I want to
explain to people how beautiful uh
Calamity can be so sometimes we look at
these difficulties as you know something
that can break us down but when we
understand that it's our Divine Design
our our creator if you will giving us
the opportunity to make choice to change
and that's why I love Dr wallick's work
with epigenetics because we are not a
victim of our genetics when we can
understand action reaction just like if
you were to look at a car and understand
how that works you can do the same with
the human body most of us are not very
aware of how our bodies actually work so
in my case you know I started with these
hives it took me down this long path of
learning how to be responsible for my
health and at 21 years old I met Dr
Carol gck who is was a practicing
naturopathic physician she had graduated
from Westbrook University and also
carried titles from Clayton University
and worked with uh Dr Ellen Jensen both
of which were the interns to Dr Bernard
Jensen at his Clinic the health Ranch in
ESO California in the early 90s both of
these women were the leading ladies in
doing much of his research and helping
to standardize education for idology
they also were the founding members of
what has now become the international
iridology Association for practitioners
so we call it IPA and if you ever want
to look it up it's a wonderful resource
for iridology because it standardizes
the languaging and making sure that
we're practicing uh the uh the science
of idology responsibly so we're not
making false claims and again as we all
know uh we are not here to diagnose or
prescribe we are not here to counteract
any of your medical care we're here to
be a compliment to it all and when you
understand how your health is and how it
operates then you get to become the uh
captain of your ship
so the way we look at the eyes is that
it's much like your blueprint of
information that you're given at Birth
if you think about it even in the
Scriptures it says that God knew you
before you were formed he knit you in
the womb and I Envision that being when
the iris is being formed it's almost
like a 3D printer and the iris itself is
formed fully formed at five months in
utero okay and and if you're familiar
with reflexology so we I have here a
little picture of the hands and the feet
most of you may be familiar with the uh
basic points okay now when you look at
these we have an Associated map here
also of the eyes and this map is from uh
Dr Bernard Jensen originally and has
been edited and upgraded by Dr Ellen
Jensen this is one of the most
comprehensive maps and it is now used
worldwide as a standard for
understanding the iris so as you can see
it's a blueprint of information and each
iris is so unique that you're able to
see the
patterns where they are associated to
different organs just even the color
itself describes a great deal of how
your composition your genetic structure
is governed so we like to be able to
work with the body and highlight the
strengths support the weaknesses and
really focus on how much uh Power you as
an individual has to be able to make
change so at the uh Clinic that I worked
at at uh lifestyle transformation health
and research clinic in northern Idaho I
was the technician and the intern for
three years and I studied extensively we
did blood cell live and dry blood cell
analysis as well as I ology and we also
did scarology which here is another map
this is the whites of the eyes so what
we understood is that the iris itself is
like a thumb print of genetic
information the patterns the shapes the
textures doesn't always change sometimes
the shading can change with lifestyle
changes but it's kind of what you've
been gifted with it's your house so the
whites of the eyes on the other hand
indic at more of the current
inflammation that you may be dealing
with so being able to use both resources
is able to look at what is symptomatic
and what is not so our goal as an
iridologist is to help you prevent
symptoms we do not have to be a victim
of the sins of our forefathers so to
speak and when we look at the you know
what we inherit we inherit I call it the
funnel effect so it's up to Generations
into the past that are all funneling
down into our one genetic body so these
traces of injuries pain disease that our
parents and our grandparents and their
fathers and forefathers inherited and
experienced is funneled into us now the
thing that I want to continually remind
people of is that like Dr wallik says
and he was the first to really bring
this Awareness on
epigenetics we can change what we
inherit is not just the genetic code we
often inherit the lifestyle and the
lifestyle that our parents and
grandparents had is what often created
the disease and in today's world it's
predominantly due to poor
nutrition food is our first medicine and
in our culture and our world right now
now our food is deficient our soil is
deficient we have pollution on high
levels in our our soil our water our
Cosmetics almost every hygiene product
is covered in in and uh chemicals and
we're putting them onto our skin most
people don't think of the skin as being
your largest living organ and if you put
something on your Skin Within 26 seconds
it's in your bloodstream
so when we start to look at our whole
body our body Temple which is my brand
Body Temple Health we want to create a
sanctuary for our souls to take up
residents because when we're distracted
by pain disease
discomfort that is when we are unable to
execute our purpose and be able to live
in alignment with our design and fulfill
our destiny essentially it's so that's
why for me cleansing has been a huge
part of my practice and I'm so excited
to work with Dr Wallock team and his
product line because I've been looking
for one that I feel is reputable that
has researched its uh formulas and I am
100% impressed to see everything that's
uh I've been able to look through
because it addresses so many of these
deficiencies so um we have so many of
them now because it's chronic okay you
know if you look at a at a tree which
mind you uh my book is uh called awaken
and become a tree of life always be
cleansing so the theory on that is if we
look at each body like we are a tree
then if we give it the proper air water
soil and food the nutrition and sunlight
that we can actually be become a radiant
tree of life and when we are all
operating at our optimal levels imagine
the network that we can create as a
forest of global living trees of life
that are bearing fruit that are uh
upright I always think of Integrity too
when we have an upright nature then our
actions our words our Deeds the things
we put in our mouth illuminate ourselves
cells the things we speak illuminate
others and we come into alignment with a
higher frequency of living so I call it
clearing the corrosion from the battery
cable let's get the uh the the fungus
the parasites the heavy metals the heavy
energies out of our bodies so that we
can radiate at a higher frequency when
we have all of our minerals the 90
essential minerals when we have our
enzymes in order when we do our detoxes
and I and I want to really clarify the
standard of uh languaging so I've used
the term or Dr Christine Maxwell who I
wrote the book introduced the term
always be cleansing to me
ABC now a lot of the times in our
culture we look at cleansing is a
seasonal thing and what I want to bring
to the awareness is cleansing is like
cleaning up your house you need to wipe
the counters sweep the floors take the
trash out regularly and when we think of
our cleansing organs then we need to
make sure that our elementary canals are
working optimally so that's our colon
our kidneys our skin and our lungs and
we have to realize how important it is
to support our liver although it's not
an Elementary Canal it's a filter and it
filters all of our blood so when we eat
foods that are high in acid forming
constitutions or if they have chemicals
preservatives right then we're going to
have higher uric acid in the blood now
when that higher uric acid is present
our body has to stay stable with the
blood or we end up having uh Cardiac
Arrest it could be very very serious so
the liver is the goalkeeper the liver
filters the uric acid out of the blood
to maintain
homeostasis so the liver then becomes
the distributor it's the manager who
tells okay we're going to send carbon
dioxide out to the lungs we're g to send
uric acid out which is urine think of
that urine is actually
filtered
blood so when you are supporting your
kidney system with proper hydration
which mind you is not just the quality
or the quantity of the water that you're
drinking but it's also the electrolytes
and and uh making sure that you have
your potassiums all your chlorides
everything in order so that your body
becomes electric it actually can conduct
energy better and when we have our
electrolytes it makes it so that our
cells absorb water it's the Catalyst for
hydration and so and I'm not talking
salt like uh you know sodium that we get
from especially the iodized form Mor and
salt that stuff is not good for you I'm
talking about the trace minerals the 90
minerals that are also present in sea
salt right so Dr wallik has formulated
some really great products to be able to
make it easy and um accessible and
assimilable a lot of the times
supplements out there today are not
assimilable and you have to be careful
of synthetics okay and that's why I love
young jevity what they're promoting what
they've formulated very well researched
in their product line making sure that
the ingredients are coming from high
qual quality food based ingredients
because this is important so that each
cell can actually uptake it otherwise
it's just pumping through the system and
um it's likely to not be able to be
absorbed so then you're also wasting
money if you think about it so get the
good stuff get the things that you know
will be uptaken by your
bloodstream and support those elementary
canals so cleansing is an everyday thing
ABC it's the building blocks to
self-care making sure your bowel
eliminates every day make sure your
kidneys you have enough hydration so you
keep all the the uric acid in a solution
so it can be excrement otherwise uric
acid and I've seen it in blood work okay
it is little crystals those little
crystals if they can't get out they're
going to turn around and settle then the
joints the tissues the ligaments it's
possible to create irritation if you see
a little Crystal it's kind of like
having a stone in your shoe there's
going to be irritation for the
surrounding tissues now our body is so
wise you know we were we were created
with infinite wisdom so we actually our
body pumps out mucus as a natural
alkaloid and when we understand that
then we can see that anytime we have a
little extra mucus it's our biof
feedback system saying you're going
acidic all right because it's pumping
out to try to dissolve those little acid
crystals and protect your tissues by
being kind of viscous now the thing
about mucus is if we don't change our
diet and we keep eating acid forming
foods which are mucus forming right then
that mucus will become more stagnant and
it I call it like the fly trap for
fungus bacteria yeast virus and uh
especially for parasites so we want to
be mindful of always watching our
indicators let's listen to our bodies
it's constantly communicating with us
and the more we listen just like you
were saying Dr Becca um you can actually
receive the information it will come to
you and you can understand what it is
you're in need need of and and start
really um being aware of your choices so
I'm all about making sure we prevent
mucus by eating alkaline foods so
there's the 80 20% chart that some of
you may have heard about you want to
focus on 80% of your diet being alkaline
forming and that will reduce the acids
that are going to be coming into the
bloodstream if you're dealing with
illness
I would say and Dr sa from uh Honduras
who's now gone he always said 15% or
less acid forming Foods so that you can
do repair so your body doesn't have to
work so hard and I also heavily promote
using alkalizing tonics so we've all
heard about lemon we've all heard about
apple cider vinegar I have a lot of
clients who've had issues with teeth
enamel and and maybe some of you know
what I'm talking about if you do too
many acids in your drinks it's likely to
dissolve your tooth enamel so looking at
alternate ways of getting these amazing
tonics in without damaging the teeth and
I'll have to say Dr Wall's uh gummies
that are the apple cider vinegar gummies
it's
revolutionary because it's an easier way
to get it in and children okay the
elderly you don't have to force them to
drink some kind of apple cider tonic and
you can also do a neutraceutical option
for alkalizing my suggestion with the
gummies because they're 500 milligrams
per serving in my book it talks a lot
about alkalizing and I have the tonics
in there but I would say uh to swap and
use the gummies if you are not
interested in doing the tonics it's much
easier you don't have to carry around
jars and bottles and teaspoons and try
to mix stuff especially for those of you
who may be busy on the go work um and I
would suggest using it five times a day
every three hours doing a serving of
apple cider vinegar alongside of a
highly alkaline diet okay and if you
want to do a seasonal detox so the
difference between cleansing and
detoxification to me is cleansing is
your daily counter sweeping and
detoxification is when you're going to
go in and steam clean the organs and
dust off the fan so to speak and get
into those nooks and crannies within
your digestive system but also
throughout your entire body and that's
what Dr Bernard Jensen really brought to
the Forefront in his book tissue
cleansing through bowel management is
that you use the bowel like you would
the Columbia River to get everything
from all the tributaries all the
lymphatic vessels all the nervous system
everything to dump into the bowel and
then be eliminated and obviously uh
using the skin and the kidneys and
supporting them in their elimination as
well so for me I can only speak about my
personal experiences but using this
method this hybrid way of cleansing
where you're not
uh going into states of deficiency
because we don't need to do that we want
to do hypernutrition
nutriceutical where we use supplements
high nutrition food tonics for
alkalizing and you can actually feed
your system well okay and so I have my
testimonial just from this last winter
um I had some ovarian cysts and I was
suffering with Hashimoto symptoms from
uh stress from a couple years back and I
also had a little fatty cyst here at the
back of my oxa put so when I started
writing my book I decided to practice
what I preach and I put myself on the
alkaline forming Foods did the tonics
and I did bathing enemas dry skin
brushing and oiling of the skin
alongside of high doses of water of
course to keep the fluids moving now
within uh I happened to get some uh CT
of my abdomen done and that's when they
showed me that I had ovarian cyst on the
left side and uh I did six weeks of my
program with Blended soups predominantly
so that I took the pressure off of the
gut as well and enzymes with every meal
is really helpful for rebuilding the
digestive system and uh lo and behold in
six weeks those cysts had complet
dissolved so and this fatty cyst at the
back of my neck has reduced by about
70% now as for the Hashimoto all of my
numbers have been reversed my T3 and T4
were skyrocketing off of the RoR it was
like at at a 10 point 7 point they
wanted to put me on leave with the roxin
um I took my time to do my cleansing
nutriceuticals the green foods are
really important for Pulling heavy
metals out for and then the alkalizing
and I all my numbers are reversed and I
just have to give God the glory because
it it takes Faith okay we think about
faith as believing in the things that
are
unseen so yes that is believing in
something that you cannot see like God
Force energy right beyond that what I've
discovered is seeing the future for you
your Optimal Health your optimal life
something that may be feeling really
obscure so in my case when I've been
covered in hives and my last Bel was
right after my mother passed and it it
was nine months every single day of
being covered in these welts
and you know it's real easy in those
states to kind of throw in the towel and
give up and you want a magic pill you're
in so much distress
right and I just want to encourage
people to know that the path of natural
health is a
slower uh opportunity to heal but it's
lasting okay it is an investment in your
future our health is our wealth how are
you
investing and know to have patience
because when you're receiving these
blessings and your wellness and you're
reversing illnesses to have that
patience is what gives you the
opportunity to actually be able to
experience the joy of being in wellness
and so yeah it took nine months for me
and there were times where I thought
well maybe I'm supposed to just do what
the doctors are telling me and the Lord
kept telling me
no you know this is the right way this
is the way to heal is through nature and
we have been given our
hands okay we have been given food and
we have all of these beautiful resources
to us especially water and the Earth so
when we can utilize our natural elements
and be wise because we've been given
Minds we've been given the discernment
something that uh you know our animals
Kingdom doesn't have we get to make
choice and we can choose and that's why
they say many are called but the chosen
are few and I look at that more as we're
all called okay whether it's death
disease divorce when we have
difficulties in our life I believe that
is our
calling all right now the difference is
we've all kind of I thought that maybe
we're supposed to wait for our for
healing for the Miracles no it's a
process of us doing the choosing okay
because we can sit you know faith
without works is dead so we must be
activated we can't just sit and pray we
need to make choices every day that come
into alignment with our Divine Design
and I call it the marble theory is my
story but I like to add one good thing
at a time kind of like the gold foil
stars for your
kids instead of going into shame and
saying oh I shouldn't do this and I
can't do that and then you start to deal
with your inner teenager that most
likely is going to Rebel so when we
actually look at a reward system and
it's an endorphin reward it's not like
you're going to go get chocolate cake
but you're going to be like uh
congratulate yourself maybe even have
that special little thing that you're
going to kind of uh promote in your life
I like to use self-care I used to love
chocolate cake and ice cream and popcorn
and all the things that made me sick so
when we can shift it and self-care is
the active state of
self-love so when we are choosing things
that are not good for us and we know it
okay it's like the dog that returns to
its vment that in itself is the worst
for us we know it's bad and we're still
going to consume it then we've created a
uh more of a a programming because we're
cursing ourselves as we eat something oh
I shouldn't and this is so bad for me
right so when we can go into self-love
we can celebrate our wins and you know
when I have big Cravings I'll I'll run a
bath I'll get in the shower I'll I'll
take the time for self-care for loving
this
for cleaning this Temple so that I can
invite the soul to take up residence and
in that Stillness is when we get the
relief in that Stillness is when we get
the messages and the answers sometimes
to our prayers to our lives that feel
really difficult and hard to get around
um but that's kind of a an overview of
of my theories and the way that I look
at wellness it's all about the holistic
holy
truly as uh being as a creation and so
when we look at our Roots as our
digestive system on the tree all right
what kind of soil are you putting in to
your digestive system and enzymes are
essential for breaking food down most of
us have not been eating properly you
know we weren't taught properly
especially food combining most people
don't understand but if you put a
protein in the same room as a
starch protein requires an acidic enzyme
to break it down starches required an
alkaline enzyme to break it down when
you put an acid and an alkaline in the
same room they neutralize each other so
now you have indigestion it's just not
going to break down at all and you can
have more
fermentation so there's actually studies
of blood gases that come through the
digestive system due to fermentation and
it can actually uh mimic blood alcohol
there's some people who have blown a
breathalizer due to fermentation in the
gut and never even consuming any
alcohol so when we look at this we can
stop all of that by focusing on our 8020
chart and I highlight the proper food
combining chart when you can understand
what you're eating when and why and
combining things properly so I always
tell my clients pick one a protein or a
starch now add green vegetables you
can't go wrong there if you're going to
eat fruit do it alone preferably earlier
in the day so it goes down the tube
first and doesn't get trapped behind the
proteins that take a much longer time to
digest if the fruit gets stuck behind
that protein then you're going to have
have a lot of fermentation and that is
where I mean what's how is wine made
it's fermented fruit so people are
actually generating I call it a brewery
in the digestive system and they're
absorbing these blood alcohols and talk
about feeling Moody lethargic exhausted
uh depressed you know it's the off
gassing of these things and so we want
to really work with digestion and with
enzym
and that's why I love Dr Wall's products
and his cleanse options too because I'm
all about hydrotherapy and I really
encourage people if you to consider
colonics uh and enemas potentially if
you're really dealing with high degrees
of um toxicity in the body but it's not
convenient for everyone and I understand
that it's it's in our culture it can be
a little little uncomfortable
so Dr uh wallik has several formulas the
30-day detoxes that I think are
excellent for your userfriendly
opportunity and you can do that I mean
Dr uh Jensen he suggested cleansing four
times a year so basically every time you
have a seasonal change okay it's a good
time to cleanse just like you would in
your house right you do spring cleaning
you do fall cleaning especially because
of the changes in the seasons and um
sometimes in between because when you're
just like in your closet when you got to
change your clothing out based on the
seasonal changes think of that for your
intestinal system all right cleansing it
out right and I use a term called Purge
to
emerge once we are releasing those
things that no longer serve us we are
not weighted down and we can soar okay
and we become lit up literally there's
studies on biophotonic light emissions
in the cells so when we're operating at
a high frequency with the electrolytes
uh seriously charging every single cell
literally there is light to be detected
and we go right back to that Matthew
6:24 let thine eye be pure let thine eye
be full of light so our cells are full
of light and I see the eyes is kind of
like your thermometer
so when your eyes get uh red weepy
irritated it's kind of at the top of the
thermometer and in herring's law of cure
the best way we heal is uh from the top
down and so your inflammation will start
to be reduced and you almost have to
somewhat go back in time through your
symptoms potentially to get back to
homeostasis and that's why they call it
cleansing crisis sometimes
and if you push your body too hard
without getting the elimination going
that is when those toxins will kind of
back back up and you reabsorb them and
that's why making sure your bowel is
going regularly every day especially
while you're taking a detox product
especially while you're trying to remove
heavy metals you've got to get them out
otherwise it's stirring up the dust and
it's going to end up somewhere else and
that can create more of an issue so um
as far as for
iridology the most beautiful thing is
being able to see
infation so you can uh formulate a plan
for each individual that's more based on
their genetic needs versus blanket
theories you know eat right for your
blood type and we have a lot of great
ideas and definitely they're applicable
but it's not a standard for every
everyone and then you add personalities
so in the iris you can also see the
person's uh way of thinking the way they
process information the way they do
things naturally and being able to use
that as well to work with people their
emotions their unresolved trauma to be
able to formulate a plan that they can
digest all right because it's about
meeting the individual where they're at
not trying to force feed them on
something it is about working with them
so that they can integrate Wellness in
without feeling like they are uh
imprisoned by this new standard or
living this rule-based life they can
actually do it in a way that feels
joyful and integrated and they feel
empowered and free because that's what
we're really looking for is freedom we
want to be free of the ways of the world
that have been put upon
us all right we didn't ask for these
things for the the pollution and
everything that we're in ex exposure to
on a regular basis however we are
exposed to them so we need to be able to
maintain power and Sovereign power to
reduce the inflammation because I see
basically all illness is inflammation
which is predominant caused by metabolic
wastes and
acidosis all right anytime you add uh
chemicals preservatives toxins then
you're going to up those uh toxic uh
levels in the blood so we're already
dealing with just basic um inflammation
from our metabolical system going on and
then you add all these other things and
today I just want to also really
highlight
how our children have been so inundated
all right not only have most parents not
really thought about preparing for
having a child all right that's
something Dr Bernard Jensen really
looked into and even Dr wallik focuses
on helping the families prepare for
children how to raise the children so
that they get the nutrition that they
need and how to teach them how to walk
in the world because today's world it I
mean whether it's the handheld devices
so they're already being exposed to so
many
electromagnetics but the food the
Cosmetic
industry um and it's it's uh very
difficult to watch because of course our
children want to quote fit in in their
school systems but uh there's a lot of
this that is really targeting children
and and we're having illnesses in young
people that should never have been there
before uh they used to come in and
elderly and now we're seeing them in our
teenagers in Mental Health crisis and a
lot of it's based on food based on
minerals not being present and even and
I'll touch real briefly there's a lot to
do with the MTHFR gene mutation which uh
we'll do a separate show on but I really
want to bring that awareness to people
that if there's any mental health issues
especially in your family your children
please look into getting that genetic
test done so you can understand the
methylation in the body methylation is
what naturally does
detoxification there is a huge
percentile of people who are not
methylating now due to this mutation
which makes it so that they're actually
um unable to get toxins out of their
body and if they're getting synthetic
vitamins they are actually having
allergic reactions to that
so it's not even like sometimes we all
focus on gluten being such a terrible uh
food product which mind you it is acid
forming but wheat god-given to us camut
or inspell in the original
grains they uh were complete food and
you have to look at what the biggest
problem with the wheat industry besides
the glyos fates from the you know
Monsanto and whatnot is the enrichment
because it's all enriched with with
synthetic vitamins folic acid and
riboflavin in particular what we are
needing is methyl folate and methyl
cobalamine and those are in Dr Wall's
product the Tangerine one and um this is
a vital part we don't understand the
sequence I've I've been doing a deep
dive on it but we need the methyl folate
in order to uptake iron and we need iron
in order to update oxygen so people who
are oxygen
deficient or having diff thick blood is
because they actually are really in need
of this nutrition and the minerals and
they can reverse it just by providing
them with the the uh few essentials and
it can help uh get them to absorb
everything now I do see that it looks
like I have a couple of questions
possibly is there anything else I should
share
Becca well we do have hands with
questions and I know we're going to have
a lot more questions and so we already
have over four months of to set up for
Dr Cara and so I'm super duper excited
now you're talking about you know eating
more alkaline food folks eat your
vegetables eat your
fruits yes but you remember
that because of farming practices they
no longer have the minerals so we must
be intentional in making sure that we're
getting the minerals and the 90
essential nutrients now it is the Beyond
Tangy Tangerine 2.5 version of the
product that has those methylated B
vitamins and folate so I'm super excited
that we brought that out within the last
two years we as in youngevity brought
that out within the last two years and
it's an answer to a call meeting people
where they're at and the needs that
people have so that they can also
obtain Better Health now not being able
to eliminate those toxins or
detoxify that is something that it makes
it pure and just so simple people say I
have the MTHFR Gene okay well what is
that you know because this is big long
word
basically not able to detoxify
themselves not able to get those toxins
out of the
system
so I have I have lots of comments coming
into to me personally um in the chat and
also through text messages just loving
your message your energy so I'm super
excited as we continue to have you on
with us now we do have some some eyes to
look at so we'll do one but let's go
ahead and
let's okay I'm sorry oh sorry let let me
make sure this is taken care
of thank
you sorry about
that wonderful I can't wait to hear what
everyone has uh Curious to hear more
information
on well AJ is the first to have his hand
up so AJ go ahead and yourself
good to see you again Dr
Cara likewise I'm so glad that you're
you're on the team you're you're you're
a bundle of energy but the only thing I
want to know yes is I want to see your
you see you just you added more things
today you just said that you can see
someone's personality in the
eyes yes see now if you're looking at my
eyes you're gonna guess my personality
so it's like that's not really fair um
but I'm very curious to see you do an
eye analysis I really need to see this
okay well I'm eager to do so I have uh a
couple of eyes or sets of eyes that we
get to look at today well let's have at
it Miss
okay fabulous somebody
M thank you AJ um so first let's go head
and Marilyn do you have a quick
question yeah I had an I can you hear me
I had an eye analysis done many years
ago and they said I'm super super
sensitive I didn't know what it means
and he says the guy goes and you have
anger uh in your gallbladder and he said
on your father's side is this things you
can even see like versus mother's side
versus father's side I mean I was like
what and so I don't know I guess I carry
that with me I don't know
I love it no this is very uh uh in Denny
Johnson's work which is the red uh form
of iridology it focuses on the
personality and you can see birth order
as well as what you inherit
predominantly from your mother and your
father the right eye carries more of
your father's genetics and the left eye
more of your mother's
genetics and in my eyes for instance I
have a mark in the
area of the right eye that is specific
to inheriting uh or to a forefather
having tuberculosis okay well what's
interesting is when I started doing the
research indeed my great great
grandparents died of tuberculosis on my
father's
side and it was genetically handed down
four generations back yeah wow that's
fascinating and then one other thing
it's pretty fascinating they they saw um
little yellow specks of fat in the blood
I guess that's that's what it was I
didn't know at the time and I didn't
know but it's result of eating too much
sugar right you're seeing these yellow
specks in the blood anyway he said he
showed me the blood he showed me it and
he said you not have these little specks
in your blood and that was like year
2000 okay that sounds like about the
time that I was behind the
microscope um you can even fat in the
blood Through The Eyes yeah fat in the
blood and you can see fat in the whites
of the eyes so a lot of people get that
little we call it a pinguecula it's a
fat the little deposit that's often
yellow or it's like a little blob in the
eye or the cornea actually and that
shows that you're not able to digest fat
cells but as we know you're right what
does fat come from but predominantly
from
sugar everyone talks about fat but
actually in the 80s when we went the fat
or went on the fat free
fad we actually created a lot of
problems and and I have a theory that's
likely associated to some of the
dementia and Alzheimer's issues we're
seeing in our elders today who were
predominantly told to go on fat free we
need good fats for the
brain okay the brain needs those oils
the skin needs those oils the problem is
we're eating rancid oils most of the
time and we need good oils and so uh I
was listening to uh Dr fuches Ben fukes
show talking about the efas and the
omegas and how important that is for the
brain for the good oils even the coconut
oil that has high caprylic acid and the
hdls and the ldls actually helps lower
high cholesterol but we've been and
steriles in general if we don't have
fats we can't generate
hormones so the problem is sugar and
especially the refined forms of it you
know good sugars has trace minerals in
it and all the things but we want to
keep the glucose levels
lower you know but yeah this is
incredible fascinating to see it to see
it to actually visually see it thank you
absolutely thank
you next you Marilyn and hey Maryland
it's been 24 years since you've had one
you've been on some really good
supplements for the last six seven years
might be time for another eye analysis
which Dr Cara does do so folks if you're
interested in a hair an eye analysis
okay Dr W promotes hair analysis Dr Cara
does the eye analysis
um she is open for doing that of course
there is a fee we don't want to make
sure we want to make sure that her time
is um compensated so you can get a hold
of Dr Cara several different ways okay
carbody Temple
health.com again that's Cara C A A the
at sign Body Temple health.
so that's the way we're going to share
with you right now um for those of you
who didn't catch that and want to reach
out to us you can get a hold of us
through our website using that contact
option we'll make sure that we have the
information to the whole team so that
you can get in touch with Dr
Cara as well so we're real coming close
on time and the next hand up is a set of
eyes that we're going to be looking at
so y
yes um so
Rod go ahead and unmute yourself can you
hear me H yes yes I have a I have a um a
distributor that says how do you get
your acine food chart is what you want
to
know what was that again where do you
get your acine food chart you can find
it in my book which is on Amazon
currently and I also have the workbook
that goes with it this promotes eight
days of of self-care and basically walks
you through much of what I've introduced
to you today on proper nutrition proper
food combining and doing it from a
food-based state and uh I would love to
be able to add an Anum with any of this
that we can really tailor a lot of these
products that to help support the
individuals in their Wellness as well so
that they don't have to focus so much on
making so much food sometimes you can
actually go and be traveling and still
have all of your nutrition and
especially because as Dr D or as we were
also discussing um the food or the soil
is deficient so even when we're getting
good food it's not the same degree of
minerals and nutrition that was
originally in Garden of Eden for
instance we are in a deficient state so
adding in these uh mineral in particular
is important really
important
yeah and thank you thank you thank you
folks for those of you who are here with
us on how you can get a hold
of
yes always be cleansing and the work and
the book itself is also on Kindle
so go ahead and check out uh the
information in the chat there we'll make
sure that we also get that available in
the newsletter that we send out with the
copy of today's replay so are you ready
to do an oh I am it's my favorite thing
I I I think of them as beautiful marbles
I get to
collect each one is
unique let me go ahead and do a screen
share here
okay
wonderful all right this is oh wonderful
so this is the beauty of my the way I
work is I can do a lot of work remotely
and these are photos that have been
taken off of a smartphone so they are
perfectly adequate for being able to get
us a good idea of where to start for
iridology now with the dark eyes the
brown eyes it can be a little more
difficult to see the fabric of the
patterns but it still gives us so much
information so what I see here is a
hematogenic iris so hematogenic is
meaning Brown um and really over 90% of
the population has brown eyes globally
it's a genetic strength now what we're
also seeing here is that it's um uh the
hematogenic body is governed by the Hema
so the blood any of the blood congestion
issues are common in the family heritage
typically of a brown-eyed person that
could include cholesterol uh heart
issues it can include um varicose veins
uh sometimes gout is predominant
recording stopped and sometimes recing
in progress here we go and sometimes
diabetes can be common as well for
people with the blood conditions so we
want to be able to help prevent these
things by keeping the blood balanced and
so as we were talking about with the uh
the vitamins with methyl folate and iron
it's important to feed the blood with
these things so I would suggest an iron
supplement I would also suggest um
potentially doing um it looks to me in
the right
Iris if you look to if you look at the
eyes kind of like a clock dial so at the
top being noon and the bottom being six
right right at about I would
say uh about 7 P.M we can see that
there's a vein in the white of the eye
and that shows that there's a potential
for having some liver
congestion so uh I would suggest
especially because it's kind of spring
still it's a good time for a seasonal
cleanse to do the 30-day liver cleanse
to support the liver which again what
does the liver do filters the blood so
it's kind of like the air filter to a
car only we don't get to replace it our
body is so ingenious it actually will
just get a bigger liver so the en larged
livers fatty livers often come from
congested blood conditions and the
workload being put on the liver so when
we cleanse the liver we cleanse the
filter so to speak and we make it so
that our bodies work so much better the
other thing I see here is that it's a a
neurogenic Iris which means it's a
strong silk-like structure meaning
you're very resilient the uh body heals
really well and most likely doesn't deal
with a lot of symptoms now the
challenging part with this though is uh
often times the individual because they
don't notice symptoms they can push
themselves a little hard and we call it
burning the candle at both ends so often
times the more the resilient person they
they may have a Health crisis later in
their 40s 50s and 60s that they didn't
see coming because they just pushed past
the feelings of being tired and things
like that so with this particular
structure it's important to remind
yourself to take time for quiet take
time for rest and balance that now as a
personality you are very balanced in
general you're also really good at
planning and so there's an ability for
you a sense of knowing to see the right
it's not even right or wrong it's just
the proper way that things can be done
to create efficiency and Effectiveness
it's a very good uh personality
essentially for leadership for
organizations for uh creating policies
and executing plans um and you can also
see that you have what we call
is um a little bit of a ring of purpose
which is the dark ER exterior so your
eye is very dark in general but you can
see there's a little bit more of a
richer tone at the outer edge of the
iris that indicates that there's a a
sense of purpose on a spiritual level
that there was kind of this Burning
sense maybe even especially in your teen
years and your 20s of like I have
something to do you know it's like kind
of feeling like you're you're you have
somewhere to go but you don't know where
so the more you've been able to
actualize who you are and create a plan
then that sense of purpose feels
fulfilled okay and it's very important
to feel fulfillment so that you get you
know rest well at night you feel
accomplished every day um and on a
physical level it can also indicate that
the skin can have a difficult time
eliminating and making sure to sweat
regularly is important to open those
channels up to prevent uh putting any
kind of synthetic lotions chemicals
colog on the skin also and I understand
I mean I'm a huge fan of essential oils
and Dr wallik has an incredible line of
essential oils that are reputable and
it's important to know your source for
essential oils making sure that they are
not solvent
extracted um but you know essential oils
are the blood of the plant and um you
can really get a lot of of benefit from
the chemistry of the essential oils when
you apply it directly to the Skin So for
you I would suggest adding a lot of
grapefruit would help the lymphatic
system move um if you're feeling a
little bit
sluggish and using I I mean I'm a huge
fan of oil in general castor oil is
excellent for keeping the tissue osmotic
and supple you look at uh someone an
elderly they when we're first born we're
about 72% water and people who are in
their Elder years and suffering from
disease are often down in the 50 to 60
percentile of being
hydrated so we want to keep those
tissues Supple now the other way to do
that is with lein and silica as
nutrients and that's also including your
B vit vitamins these are all the the
necessary ingredients and proteins a
good V the shake the protein shake all
of that is the essential uh nutrition to
build connected tissue which is your
your veins everything about you is
connective tissue so um that's just a
quick little
overview I could give you a lot more but
I want you to be able to digest it do
you have any questions
no I was very impressed when we met and
you did the analysis in person and it
was very very thorough about what we
talked about because uh I was familiar
with the vital skin and also had did the
health evaluation and everything led to
the digestive system and soon as we
talked that was the first thing you said
was uh you saw the digestive thing going
on in my body through my eyes so I knew
that you were very accurate from what
you told me and showed me so it's very
impressive I know that it can go in very
great detail and it takes time but I
thank you so much for what you have done
and such a short period of time so I
encourage anyone to get it done because
I know the great detail that you can go
into so thank you so much well thank you
yes typically when I do a an official
analysis I will look over the iris and I
uh have several tiered packages some
that if you just want some general
information kind of like what we just
did here today Rod that focuses on your
eye color um and your basics of
nutrition now if you have chronic
conditions and you're really looking at
trying to get to the root of it or
needing help
translating uh your blood work or uh
coming up with questions to engage with
your your uh alpath Physicians those are
my passion projects I love to be able to
help people to become empowered and we
can go through it uh Brick by Brick and
come up with a solution for you and a
plan that integrates alpath because the
best thing about food as your first
medicine is it's not in conflict with
alpath you know and and that's where
even Dr wallet's supplements it may say
the word supplement but all of it is
food based okay and that is something
that's really beautiful in today's world
is staying close to the source because
otherwise we're getting out there into
synthetics and isolates and getting into
um it's it's out of balance then so we
want to stay as close to the source and
that's why I'm so happy to work with
this company thank
you awesome that's
incredible um I absolutely love it and
when you talk about
holistic I mean you touched on a lot of
different aspects in life which is
exactly part of what we do in the
certified holistic health coach course
so but
iridology um which is something we don't
touch in and that's where it we are so
blessed to be able to have Physicians
such as Dr car ringland as part of our
team and helping each and every one of
us be able to achieve Optimal Health so
again you can get uh with the person
that shared this program with you say
hey I want more information inform and
hopefully they'll be able to connect you
with the information to get a hold of Dr
Cara if not you can always call our call
team I'll make sure that each and every
one of them on the call team has Dr
Cara's information as well you can reach
us by going to
3377 and please make sure that you let
the team know and let Dr Cara know
if you are working with a youngevity
distributor already we want to make sure
that if you're working with somebody
already that you get referred back to
them with the program that is being
recommended for you if you're not
working with somebody already and we
want to make sure that Dr Cara knows
that so that she can help you get the
products um and as part of the team you
know we all work together so we are
super excited Dr Cara to have you as
part of our team what an amazing hour we
didn't even get to the second I analysis
so we'll do that at another time um
which I'm super excited personally
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say about
that
okay well if folks if I could get my
team on the on the screen with us that
would be absolutely
fantastic um of course Dr Cara let's
give up for her amazing amazing thank
you for blessing us with your knowledge
and your wisdom and your
voice your voice that shares so much
knowledge and just feeds into
us the positive energy we need to know
we're in the right
place
amen yeah we have with us my executive
production manager Ruth Ellen Sanchez
who's keeping us all organized thank you
so much Ruth Ellen we have Marilyn who
is putting amazing notes into the chat
which is one of
the finest reasons for being on with us
in our live Zoom because that
information is not shared on the
different different uh broadcasts or
streams so thank you Marilyn for all
that you do with that we have sherry who
is helping us let people in keep an eye
on cameras making sure that it's a safe
place for all ages to be thank you
Sherry and we have Coach Rod who is
doing the same um in making sure that
people get in in a timely manner and
bringing and stepping up showing his
eyes as being a first example of what Dr
Cara is all about and we also have
Albert way down in South Africa letting
people in and helping us reach those
people that are outside of the United
States borders so if you're outside of
the United States folks don't hesitate
to reach out if you're not working with
somebody we have Distributors around the
world who want to help you find your
Optimal Health Journey as
well and we have AJ who is currently on
the phone helping somebody that has
called in um AJ is one of the reasons
why we are able to be on so many
different platforms as he took the time
and and just took charge of that project
and made things happen just want to do a
big shout out and thank you to AJ and
all of my team I could not do this
without them without their skills
without their emotional support and love
folks we are a holistic community that
works together and we're here to help an
even greater community Community as a
resource to them and putting Tools in
their toolbox with knowledge and what
needs to be done to help those around
them as well so again thank you so much
for joining us here on daily with Doc
and Becca my name's Becca dukes and it
is my honor and privilege to welcome
again Dr Cara ringland to our team until
next
time bye don't forget folks Mondays
Mondays are Dr Cara days so mark that on
your calendar 12 to 1 pm Pacific Time by
going to daily withth do
zoom.com of course you can catch the
replays but there's nothing like being
here in the zoom room with us seeing
that chat and asking your questions bye
for now bye thank you
[Music]
a
this program is for educational purposes
only the content is not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
diseases nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician the
statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA testimonials are
shared as individual experiences of the
individual results vary and may not be
typical we do not make any claims
regarding health or income as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain Optimal
Health Dr Joel wall
[Music]
la
this program is for educational purposes
only the content is not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
diseases nor is it intended to take the
place your primary care physician the
statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA testimonials are
shared as individual experiences of the
individual results very and may not be
typical we do not make any claims
regarding health or income as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain Optimal
Health Dr Joel wall
[Music]